beginnen wir mit einer Frage wusstet ihr
dass Konflikte zwischen Ländern die sich
länger als ein Jahr hinziehen dann oft
mehr als ein Jahrzehnt andauern es mag
euch überraschen aber solche lang
anhaltende konflikte sind nicht üblich
die meisten sind glücklicherweise nach
weniger als einem Jahr wieder vorbei
aber es gibt natürlich auch Zeiten in
denen dies leider nicht der Fall ist und
auch wenn der Krieg in Israel momentan
die Medienlandschaft dominiert wissen
wir natürlich alle dass es der Zeit
einen Krieg gibt der weit über ein Jahr
alt ist ich spreche von der
Konfrontation zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine einem Krieg der seit fast zwei
Jahren andauert und der sich nach
Meinung einige Analysten noch viel
länger hinziehen könnte das ist z.B die
Meinung des ehemaligen britischen
Generals Richard Barrons die wir schon
einmal auf visualpolitik erwähnt haben
die Ukraine kann jetzt nicht gegen
Russland gewinnen aber ein Sieg bis 2025
ist möglich die hauptlaste des Krieges
der sich immer weiter hin zeht tragen
natürlich die Ukraine sie sind es die
sich verteidigen und dabei zusehen
müssen wie die Russen ihre Städte und
Dörfer dem Erdboden gleich machen
allerdings bereitet der Konflikt auch
den Partnern der Ukraine Kopfzerbrechen
die enorme Anstrengungen unternehmen um
der Ukraine zu helfen einer sticht dabei
besonders hervor die
USA die Regierung beiden hat sich als
die engagierteste Regierung bei der
Unterstützung der Ukraine erwiesen
sowohl militärisch als auch
wirtschaftlich aber natürlich dauert der
Krieg nun schon zwei Jahre an und in
einigen politischen Kreisen in
Washington gibt es be deutliche
Anzeichen von Ermüdung manche befürchten
sogar dass sich der ukrainekrieg zu
einem weiteren endlosen Konflikt
entwickeln könnte zu einer Art neuem
Afghanistan das Milliarden von Dollar
kostet und kaum Ergebnisse bringt oder
die Aufmerksamkeit von den ihrer Meinung
nach viel wichtigeren Themen ablenkt z.B
eben des nauskonflikts oder des
wachsenden Einflusses des chinesischen
Drachen in der Welt erinnert euch bitte
daran dass es noch gar nicht so lange
her ist dass die USA einem weiteren
endlosen Konflikt mit katastrophalen
Ergebnissen entkommen sind das
Afghanistan fiasco hinterlässt den USA
bereits eine Rechnung von 2,26 Billionen
Dollar und dann hätten wir da noch die
Republikaner viel wie z.B Donald Trump
sind gegen weitere Hilfen für die
Ukraine vor allem jetzt da sie lieber
die Unterstützung Israels priorisieren
würden und vergessen wir nicht dass Ende
2024 eine Präsidentenwahl ansteht es
überrascht daher nicht dass es für Kiev
die schlimmstmögliche Nachricht wäre
wenn die USA den Hahn zudrehen würden im
Grunde würde es das Ende des Krieges
bedeuten ohne externe Waffenlieferungen
wäre die Ukraine gegen den russischen
riesen kaum noch verteidigungsfähig und
die Europäer sind momentan noch nicht in
der Lage ankel Sam sofort zu ersetzen
aber im Moment ist Washington noch voll
dabei sowohl die Dollars als auch die
Waffen fließen unvermindert weiter um
den Widerstand gegen Russland
abzusichern trotzdem sollten wir uns
angesich der drohenden und auf uns
wirklich zukommenden Risiken rechtzeitig
einige ziemlich wichtige Fragen stellen
um dann nicht plötzlich dumm aus der
Wäsche zu gucken wie viel Hilfe hat die
Ukraine tatsächlich von ihren
Verbündeten erhalten was haben die
Ukrainer mit dieser Hilfe angestellt und
inwi weit könnte die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine nachlassen heute werden wir
hier auf visualpolitik all diese Fragen
restlos beantworten und zwar gleich nach
einer kurzen Botschaft unseres Trollen
Sponsors AG1 denn schließlich hat er das
heutige Video nicht nur mit seinem
finanziellen Beitrag möglich gemacht
nein er hilft auch weit darüber hinaus
was ich damit meine nun sicher könnt ihr
euch vorstellen dass dieser Job hier
nicht durchzuhalten ist wenn man sich
nicht ordentlich inform Form hält im
vergangenen Jahr z.B war meine
Arbeitsbelastung aufgrund des Krieges
enorm angewachsen und ich hatte
Schwierigkeiten den Stress auf gesunde
Weise zu kompensieren die Folge waren
Bewegungsmangel und schlechte Ernährung
ich musste etwas unternehmen als erstes
habe ich meine Morgenroutine umgestellt
vor dem proteinreichen und zuckerarmen
Frühstück kommt jetzt immer eine Runde
Krafttraining um das Muskelwachstum
anzureden davor muss jedoch erst der
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung gebracht
werden und hierbei unterstütz mich
folgende Bestandteile meiner
allmorgendlichen Portion AG1 Kupfer
Biotin pantetonsäure tiamin und die
Vitamine B2 B12 und C und das ist nicht
einfach so daher gesagt sondern eine
evidenzbasierte Tatsache wenn ihr mir
nicht glaubt dann schaut euch doch z.B
an womit sich Joe Rogen fit hält
ebenfalls AG1 auch in den Kommentaren
unter unseren Videos schreiben uns immer
wieder viele Zuschauer die AG1
ausprobiert haben und sehr zufrieden
damit sind klar ist ein
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel wie 1 ersetzt
keine ausgewogene Ernährung deswegen
heißt es ja auch nur
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel aber es hilft
mir eben dabei mit einer gesünderen
Routine unbelastet in den Tag zu starten
allerdings ist
nicht nur für meinen individuellen
Anwendungsbereich geeignet sondern
bietet noch viele weitere
gesundheitliche Vorteile über die ihr
mehr erfahren könnt wenn ihr auf den
Link in der reibung klickt dort erfahrt
ihr auch weitere Details darüber welche
Inhaltsstoffe genau welchen Nutzen
bringen und wie sie optimal aufeinander
abgestimmt sind um Synergieeffekte und
eine hohe Bioverfügbarkeit zu erzielen
fakt ist H1 ist ketofreundlich und die
wertvollen Mikronährstoffe wurden aus
echten natürlichen veganen
Nahrungsmitteln wie Erbsen oder Soja
gewonnen ohne künstliche Zusatzstoffe
und außerdem schmeckt es auch noch gut
mir
zumindest natürlich darf man es wie
alles nicht überdosieren sollte auf
Allergen achten und vor allem nicht
einnehmen wenn man schwanger ist oder
stillt ich empfehle euch auf jeden Fall
mal eine Ernährungsberatung zu machen um
festzustellen was genau ihr braucht um
euch besser zu fühlen und gesünder zu
leben mir persönlich hilft z.B die oben
genannte Kombination mit H1 am besten
denn es deckt meiner Ansicht nach die
meisten Fälle zufriedenstellend ab und
passen dazu bietet bon unserer Community
sogar ein besonderes Angebot wenn du auf
den Link in der Videobeschreibung
klickst erhältst du bei Abschluss eines
monatlichen Abos ein kostenlosen
Jahresvorrat an Vitamin D3 und K2 und
fünf praktische AG1 travel Packs für
unterwegs gratis dazu neukundenhalten
außerdem das H1 welcome Kit inklusive
schicker Aufbewahrungsdose und einen
praktischen Shaker zur Monatspackung das
ganze ist ein Abo ohne laufzeitbindung
du kannst es jederzeit nachbelieben
anpassen pausieren und kötigigen also
worauf wartest du noch probier
noch einfach mal ganz unverbendlich aus
unterstütze auch deine Ernährung auf
einfache und gesunde Weise übrigens
falls ihr auch unsere Arbeit direkt
unterstützen möchtet könnt ihr dies über
den Spendenlink in der Beschreibung tun
auf dass wir euch noch viele weitere
interessante Videos wie dieses liefern
können und wenn ihr das erledigt habt
lasst uns zur Beantwortung unserer
brennenden Fragen schreiten wie viel
Hilfe hat die Ukraine bekommen und was
hat sie damit angestellt unter welchen
Umständen könnten die Verbündeten sie
eines Tages fallen lassen
aufgepasst Uncle Sam der große
Retter in den anderthalb Jahren des
Krieges zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine hat ein Thema die tägliche
Außenpolitik von kievs Verbündeten
dominiert ich meine natürlich das Ausmaß
der militärischen und finanziellen
Unterstützung dieses Thema ist praktisch
zum hauptfaller der westlichen
Außenpolitik geworden in dieser Zeit
haben die europäischen Institutionen
fast 85 Milliarden Euro bereitgestellt
viele davon in Form von Krediten doch
das Land das mit Abstand die meisten
Ressourcen für militärische
wirtschaftliche und humanitäre Hilfe
mobilisiert hat sind eben die USA die
rund 70 Milliarden Dollar an Hilfe
bereitgestellt haben an zweiter Stelle
folgt Deutschland das seine Bemühungen
in den letzten Monaten verstärkt hat mit
weiteren 21 Milliarden die Tatsache dass
sie die Länder sind die das meiste Geld
und die meisten Ressourcen
bereitgestellt haben bedeutet jedoch
nicht dass sie auch die größten
Anstrengung unternommen haben gemessen
am brutto Inlandsprodukt haben die USA
z.B kaum 0,3% ihrer Wirtschaftskraft in
diesen Konflikt investiert zum Vergleich
Länder wie Litauen Estland und Norwegen
liegen bereits bei fast 2%. fast 2% in
nur anderthalb Jahren das ist eine
beachtliche Zahl für Länder die keine
Truppen vor Ort stationiert haben die
Länder die auf dem Bildschirm seht sind
diejenigen die sich am meisten für die
Ukraine eingesetzt haben tja das sind
beachtliche zahlen und deswegen ist
natürlich die Frage berecht warum
westliche Länder so viel in die Ukraine
Hilfe investiert haben und warum sie
dazu überhaupt bereit
waren nun denkt mal darüber nach hätten
die Verbündeten der Ukraine nicht
geholfen das Land zu verteidigen hätte
Russland früher oder später die Oberhand
gewonnen höchstwahrscheinlich hätten wir
jetzt eine Marionettenregierung Moskaus
in Kiev installiert das wäre natürlich
ein schrecklicher präzidenfall für
andere Diktaturen mit expansionistischen
Ambitionen China z.B hätte dann
praktisch freie Hand gehabt Taiwan
einzunehmen außerdem wäre es eine
riskante Wette gewesen darauf zu
vertrauen dass die Ukrainer alle zu
Widerstandskämpfern würden die den
russischen Besatzern das Leben schwer
machen denn hätten sie gesehen dass der
Westen sie wie eine heiße Kartoffel
fallen lässt stünden die Chancen für
Putin gut dass sie sich irgendwann
frustriert wieder unter seine Führung
eingeordnet hätten tja und dann hätte er
mit einer um die gewaltige Kampfkraft
der Ukraine erweiterten Armee Genen
Westen ziehen können ein Horrorszenario
für Europa dessen Ausmaße sich
heutzutage wohl niemand wirklich
vorstellen kann ebenso können wir uns
nicht vorstellen was es für die
Weltwirtschaft bedeuten würde wenn China
Taiwan und seine Chipindustrie in die
Hände bekäme ich meine im Vergleich dazu
ist und es tut mir leid das sagen zu
müssen der jetzige Krieg für den Westen
ein echtes Schnäppchen mit extrem
niedrigen Kosten sowohl wirtschaftlich
als auch menschlich jeder Konflikt in
größerem oder kleinerem Maßstab
geschweige denn einer bei dem alliierte
Truppen vor Ort eingesetzt werden
müssten womöglich gegen eine riesige und
viel besser ausgebildete
russisch-ukrainische Armee würde viel
viel mehr kosten und es ist angesichts
des Zustand z.B der Bundeswehr fraglich
ob es nicht gar zum Zusammenbruch
Europas gekommen wäre es ist also nicht
nur so dass die Ukraine den Europäern
dankbar sein muss für deren Hilfe
sondern dass die Europäer und eigentlich
die gesamte westliche Welt den Ukrainern
unendlich viel dankbarer sein müsste
dafür dass sie anstatt ihrer für sie
kämpfen und sterben und nicht etwa gegen
sie es wurde also nicht nur zu einem
relativ günstigen Preis die Ukraine
endgültig an den Westen gebunden sondern
auch eine Großteil der russischen
Offensivfähigkeiten neutral isiert und
auch den Chinesen wurde der
Freifahrtschein für einen Durchmarsch zu
einer neuen totalitären Weltordnung
verwehrt mit anderen Worten aus
pragmatischer Sicht ist es absolut
sinnvoll die Ukraine weiterhin zu
unterstützen egal was passiert ja die
Rechnung mag riesig erscheinen aber wenn
wir alles berücksichtigen was der Westen
für Sicherheit und Verteidigung ausgibt
ist es am Ende gar nicht so viel was die
USA z.B auf den Tisch gelegt haben ist
weniger als ein Zwölftel dessen was sie
jedes Jahr für ihre eigenen Streitkräfte
ausgeben und das ist auch etwas das Joe
Biden sehr sehr deutlich gesagt
hat
die USA setzen alle Hebel in Bewegung
aber was bedeutet das und wie sie die
militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine aus die auf dem Schlachtfeld zu
dringend benötigt wird nun es geht
natürlich um massive Lieferungen von
Waffen Munition und neuen Systemen
sowohl für den Angriff als auch für die
[Applaus]
Verteidigung begann die USA mit
Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine die
natürlich seit den Beginn der russischen
Invasion intensiviert wurden mehr als 35
000 Granatwerfer Kleinwaffen tonnenweise
Munition und panzerabdesssysteme
dominieren die wiederkehrenden
Lieferungen aus den USA an die
ukrainischen Truppen darüber hinaus hat
ankelsam auch mehrere Boden
bodenraketensysteme geliefert wie z.B
die berühmte heimars mit einer
Reichweite von 80 km entscheidende 10 km
mehr als die bm30 smch die von der
russischen Armee verwendet wird und vor
wenigen Tagen gab das ukrainische
Militär bekannt dass es das von den
endlich gelieferte Army tactical missile
System attackems einsetzt das britische
Militär bestätigte dass die Waffen
eingesetzt werden und dass sie bei zwei
Angriffen auf russische
luftwaffenstutzpunkte in der Ukraine
mehr als ein Dutzend russische
Kampfhelikopter zerstört haben russische
militärblogger schrieben sogar es habe
sich um den größten Schlag gegen die
russische Luftwaffe seit dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkriegs gehandelt mehr über
den Einsatz der attack Games werde ich
euch jedoch in Kürze auf meinem neuen
Kanal erzählen ich verlinke ihn euch
hinter den eybol oben rechts damit ihr
dort vorbeischauen und ihn abonnieren
könnt ich werde dort in einem Video
klären ob es sich hierbei um einen
echten gamechanger also einen Stinger
Moment wie damals wie der sowjetischen
Besatzungszeit in Afghanistan gehandelt
hat oder ob die
Cams nicht doch überbewertet werden also
klickt jetzt ruhig auf den Link
abonniert meinen neuen Kanal mit
Glöckchen um benachrichtigt zu werden
und schaut dann dieses Video hier zu
Ende aber zurück zu den Lieferungen denn
außerdem haben die Amis hunderte von
artilleriesystemen drohen wie die
Phoenix Ghost mehr als 100 Radarsysteme
31 Panzer mehr als 200 Bradley und
Striker Panzer 1700 Stinger
Luftabwehrsysteme und das Patriot
Luftabwehrsystem in die Ukraine
geliefert die gesamte Liste ist wirklich
sehr sehr lang im Grunde haben allein
die USA der Ukraine eine ganze
armeeausrüstung zur Verfügung gestellt
sie haben sogar direkt die Lieferung von
45 d72b Panzern aus der Sowjetzeit
orchestriert diese haben die USA mit der
Hilfe Tschechiens fit für den
Fronteinsatz
gemacht und als ob das noch nicht genug
wäre kündigte beiden beim G7 Treffen im
vergangenen Mai in Japan an dass die USA
iher Partner auch bei der Ausbildung
ukrainischer Piloten an Kampfflugzeugen
insbesondere an der bekannten F16
unterstützen würden also natürlich ist
die Hilfe die die Ukraine bisher
erhalten hat keine Kleinigkeit und
vielleicht auch deshalb haben viele eine
Blitzaktion erwartet die aber nicht
stattgefunden hat nun wir haben sie
nicht erwartet aber trotzdem sollten wir
klären warum die Gegenoffensive der
Ukraine so langsam verläuft h
zu auf der Suche nach weiteren
Optionen
ich bin mir sicher viele von euch haben
gehört dass dieser Konflikt die Art und
Weise wie Kriege geführt werden
revolutioniert hat schließlich handelt
es sich um den größten Krieg seit vielen
Jahrzehnten der von einer neuen
Generation an Waffentechnologie geprägt
ist in diesem Fall spielen drohen
undbemannte Flugzeuge und sogar des
satellittenen internetprider Starling
von Elon Musk eine wichtige Rolle
entgegen den Erwartungen vieler Kremmel
bewundernder Experten spielen jedoch all
die Superwaffen mit denen Russland die
ganzen Jahre über gepralt hatte keine so
große Rolle weder mit hyperschallraket
noch dem angeblichen wunderpanzer T14
armata konnte Moskau irgendwelche
Durchbrüche erzielen die wichtigsten
russischen Trümpfe waren vor allem
menschliche fleischwellen und das
massenhafte Bombardement mit unpräziser
Artillerie aber natürlich Stunden die
Russen ohne drohen noch schlechter da
die Wahrheit ist allerdings dass dieser
Krieg den beiden Weltkriegen des 20
Jahrhunderts sehr ähnlich sieht sogar
schützengreben erleben eine späte
Renaissance und viele fühlen sich an den
Ersten Weltkrieg vor über 100 Jahren
erinnert die Artillerie spielte auch im
Zweiten Weltkrieg eine Schlüsselrolle
und heute ist die praktisch wichtigste
Waffengattung das erklärt auch z.B die
enormen Opferzahlen und die weit
verbreitete Zerstörung von Städten und
Infrastruktur die wir erleben trotz
allem hat die Ukraine tonnenweise
moderne Waffen erhalten Waffen mit denen
sie die Gegenoffensive 2023 durchführt
eine Kampagne die im Juni begann und
voraussichtlich bis zum Ende des Jahres
andauern wird wir haben ja auf
visualpolitik ein Video darüber gemacht
inem euch alle Details des ukrainischen
Vorgehens verraten klar bislang sind die
Fortschritte begrenzt das liegt zum Teil
daran dass die ukrainische Regierung
nicht bereit ist mehr zu riskieren und
schon g g nicht so viel wie einige
ungeduldige im Westen
fordern selbst als gewisse
pentagonexerten Sie aufgefordert haben
an einem bestimmten Punkt an der Front
mit massierten Kräften anzugreifen
fürchteten sie in Kiev dass sie dabei zu
viel Ausrüstung verlieren würden und
dass sie die Aktion nicht wiederholen
könnten wenn die Offensive nicht
erfolgreich verliefe es ist ein Risiko
dass die Ukrainer lieber nicht eingeen
wollen denn sie wissen ganz genau in
diesem Krieg verliert derjenige dem
zuerst die Optionen
ausgehen 24 August 2023 USA und Ukraine
streiten über die Strategie der
Gegenoffensive kievs Streitkräfte können
immer noch die russische Verteidigung
durchbrechen aber die Zeit läuft ab
sagen Washingtoner Amtsträger vergesst
bitte nicht dass sie einer russischen
Verteidigung gegenüber stehen über
Monate hinweg aufgebaut wurde und im
Grunde genommen diesem Schema folgt das
ihr hier seht ein vermentes Gebiet
panzerabwehrgräben gefolgt von
drachenzehen Schützengräben und
Artillerie und so müssen die
ukrainischen Truppen langsam vorrücken
und versuchen sich einen Weg durch die
vermieten Gebiete zu bahnen wärend sie
von russiser Artillerie Helikoptern und
drohen angegriffen werden deswegen ist
es ideal diese vorher mit der
Langstrecken Artillerie zu zerstören bzw
ihre Logistik trotzdem ist die Zahl der
Opfer hoch und eine Möglichkeit schnell
voranzukommen haben sie noch nicht
gefunden daher hoffen sie auf zermirbung
und die Kappung des russischen nschubs
aber das alles haben wir bereits im
erwähnten Video zur Gegenoffensive
detailliert erläutert die Ukrainer
wollen einfach nicht alles auf eine
Karte setzen sondern verschiedene Punkte
der Front selektiv und begrenzt
angreifen bis sie eine Lücke finden
genau das ist dann ja bei raboltina
passiert
dort gelang es ihnen eine Lücke zu
öffnen in die dann später die Stärke 82
Brigade vorstoßen konnte diese ist z.B
mit dem britischen panzerchallenger 2
ausgestattet ein weiterer Durchbruch ist
kürzlich bei der Schaffung und
Etablierung eines oder sogar zwei
Brückenköpfe am russisch besetzten
liprufer gelungen und man kann davon
ausgehen dass es den Ukrainern gelingen
wird mit der Zeit immer mehr solcheer
Lücken zu finden und auszunutzen bis die
Russen einfach nicht mehr wissen wo
Ihnen der Kopf steht allerdings das
Problem wenn man sich nicht an den
Fahrplan des Pentagons hält ist dass die
Ukraine den Versuch aufgegeben hat die
russischen Streitkräfte massiv zu
überwältigen und wisst ihr was das
eigentlich bedeutet nun es führt zu
einem viel intensiveren Verbrauch von
Munition ja die Ukraine muss die
wichtigsten Waffensysteme die an Sie
geliefert wurden schützen aber
gleichzeitig verlängert sie den
artilleriekrieg und das ständige
Tauziehen das kostet letztendlich mehr
Zeit und mehr Ressourcen aber es rettet
womöglich Menschen leben aber natürlich
müssen die Ressourcen immer noch von
ihren westlichen Verbündeten kommen tja
und genau hier stoßen wir auf ein
mögliches Problem ein längerer Krieg und
die Notwendigkeit das ukrainische
Militär ständig mit neuer Ausrüstung und
Munition zu versorgen könnten dazu
führen dass die Unterstützung im Westen
schwindet vor allem wenn ihn z.B ein
anderer Konflikt wie z.B der im Nahen
Osten oder im Südpazifik überschattet
die Frage ist also inwiew weit könnte
die kriegsmödigkeit im wen die
Unterstützung für die Ukraine gefährden
nun lasst uns das lieber mal unter die
Lupe nehmen denn schließlich hängt unser
aller Zukunft davon
ab
Gefahr durch
Erschöpfung ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass die russischen Aggressionen und ihr
brutaler Krieg in der Ukraine viele von
euch schon mal in die Verzweiflung
getrieben oder zumindest schwer
deprimiert haben das ist eine völlig
normale menschliche Reaktion auf eine
solch schreckliche Entwicklung es
handelt sich um einen quälenden und
langwierigen Konflikt der zeitweise
festgefahren zu sein scheint und aus dem
es keinen klaren Ausweg gibt aber dass
diese Stimmung in Ländern wie Österreich
Spanien Italien und Frankreich weit
verbreitet ist ist vielleicht gar nicht
so wichtig wenn sie auf die wichtigsten
Unterstützer übergreift dann ändern sich
die Dinge plötzlich steht ihr vor einer
existenziellen Bedrohung und wisst ihr
was genau das scheint in den USA zu
passieren schaut's euch an die meisten
Armes unterstützen die Ukraine aber die
langsam aufkommende mentale Erschöpfung
ist offensichtlich mehr als die Hälfte
der Amerikaner ist bereits der Meinung
dass ihr Land mehr als genug in dem
Konflikt getan hat und das sagen sie
nicht weil sie der Meinung wären dass
der Konflikt keine Bedrohung mehr für
die nationale sicherhe Amerikas oder die
Stabilität der Welt darstellen würde das
denken die meisten immer noch das
Problem ist ein
anderes die Realität sieht nämlich so
aus dass acht von zehn Amerikanern
besonders besorgt darüber sind dass der
Konflikt ewig dauern könnte das heißt
dass sich Russland und die Ukraine als
das nächste Afghanistan herausstellen
könnten und das ist der Grund für eine
weitere Statistik die selinski am
meisten sugen bereitet etwa die Hälfte
der Amerikaner manchmal sogar mehr als
50% wollen nicht dass der Kongress weit
Hilfspakete für die Ukraine bewilligt
das liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass nur
einer von vier US-Bürgern glaubt dass
die Ukraine tatsächlich erfolgreich
vorgeht erschwerend kommt deninzu dass
einige Politiker und Medien in den USA
solche Nachrichten nutzen um die Hilfe
für Europa zu kritisieren fast 90
Millionen amerikanische Erwachsene haben
laut Volkszählung Schwierigkeiten über
die Runden zu kommen aber das ist nicht
der einzige Grund im August nach dem
verheerenden Brand auf der hawaiiinsel
Maui kündigte die US-Regierung
Hilfszahlungen in Höhe von 00$ für jeden
Betroffenen Haushalt an und erntete
damit scharfe Kritik der Vorwurf die
Regierung gebe mehr Geld für die Ukraine
aus als für ihre eigenen Bürger und das
alles geschah auch noch zu einem
Zeitpunkt an dem beiden den
republikanisch dominierten Kongress
brauchte um ein neues Hilfspaket für die
ukraineen H von mehr als 24 Milliarden
Dollar zu verabschieden ohne externe
Militärhilfe wäre der ukrainische
Widerstand wahrscheinlich innerhalb
weniger Wochen
[Musik]
zusammengebrochen nun zum Glück wurden
die Hilfspakete für die Ukraine auch
diesmal bewilligt aber die extrem knappe
Einigung zwischen Republikanern und
Demokraten sorgte für einen elar bei den
Republikanern der trumpnah Abgeordnete
matt Gates hat den Vorsitzenden McCarthy
beschuldigt die Partei verraten und
gemeinsame Sache mit den Demokraten
gemacht zu haben daraufhin wurde
McCarthy sogar gestürzt und das
US-Parlament versinkt noch immer im
Chaos und GZ lässt nicht los hier sind
die 70 Republikaner im
Repräsentantenhaus die dafür gestimmt
haben die US Militärhilfe für die
Ukraine einzustellen der Abgeordnete
matt Gates hat einen Änderungsantrag
beim jährlichen verteidigungsgesetz
eingebracht um die gesamte Militärhilfe
für die Ukraine einzustellen die
Unterstützung der Ukraine in den USA
steht also auf Messers Schneide da der
trumpfügel der republikanischen Partei
strickt dagegen ist und im Wahlkampf
Jahr 2024 wirklich alles möglich sein
wird im Moment führt Trump die
vorwahlende Republikaner deutlich an und
wenn er letztendlich der Kandidat ist
und wieder Präsident wird hätte nicht
nur die Ukraine ein erstes Problem
sondern ganz Europa es verwundert nicht
dass genau dies Putins Kalkül ist er ist
sich der Situation in den US OFA bewusst
und versucht deshalb den Krieg so lange
wie möglich hinauszuzögern auch wenn es
Russland aber tausende von Menschen
leben und Hunderte von Milliarden kostet
tja und vielleicht wird er ja Glück
haben und Trump gewinnt die Wahl aber
mit den Szenarien die dann eintreten
würden werden wir uns besser in einem
eigenen Video beschäftigen vergesst also
bitte nicht unseren Kanal zu abonnieren
falls nicht schon geschehen um es auf
gar keinen Fall zu verpassen und wenn
ihr das erledigt habt würde mich erstmal
eure Meinung zu diesem Thema
interessieren wird es beiden riskieren
der Ukraine weiterhin Geld zu geben
obwohl er weiß dass diese Politik ein
Jahr vor der Wahl zunehmend und populär
ist könnte dies das Ende von bidens
Präsidentschaft und die Rückkehr von
Donald Trump herbeiführen und was denkt
ihr wie würde Trump mit dem Konflikt
letztendlich umgehen wie immer sind wir
auf eure Diskussionsbeiträge schon
mächtig gespannt falls euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und ihr dabei vielleicht et
was gelernt habt teilt mit euren
Freunden und liked es auch wie gesagt
wäre es auch cool wenn ihr unsere Arbeit
freiwillig unterstützen würdet über den
Spendenlink in der Beschreibung macht's
gut und bis
[Musik]
bald